herzlich willkommen zur folge 195 das
einspruch podcast des podcast faz
zurecht justiz und politik heute am
mittwoch den zweiten februar am mikrofon
helene bobrowski korrespondenten in
berlin und
das du dabei bist
wir haben ein volles programm heute und
ratet es geht los wieder mal mit corona
da haben wir diverse entscheidungen über
die wir sprechen müssen einerseits die
montagsspaziergänge dann müssen wir noch
nacharbeiten die impfpflicht debatte von
vergangener woche zumindest kurz und
dann gibt es noch was vom bgh was
wirtschaftlich wahnsinnig wichtig ist
zur frage ob eigentlich versicherung
zahlen wenn betriebe corona bedingt
schließen müssen das ist unser erster
teil dann sprechen wir über ein thema
das wahnsinnig traurig irgendwo ist
jedenfalls macht mich immer traurig und
nimmt mich ein bisschen mit aber es ist
natürlich auch total wichtig die debatte
um die sterbehilfe die wir schon seit
wirklich jahren wenn nicht jahrzehnten
führen und jetzt wieder eine neue lage
haben weil wir das gesetz von 2005 zehn
jahre vom bundesverfassungsgericht für
verfassungswidrig erklärt wurde und
jetzt ist im neuen bundestag neue
ansätze gibt dieses problem der
suizidbeihilfe thema sage ich noch
vielleicht neutraler der suizidbeihilfe
zu regeln da haben wir im gespräch frau
kirsten kappert gonther abgeordnete der
grünen politikerin im
gesundheitsausschuss
die es auch zu einiger bekanntheit
gebracht hat nicht nur eine impfpflicht
debatte sondern weil sie 2009 zehnmal an
der seite von cem özdemir für den
fraktionsvorsitz kandidiert hatte und
dann haben wir zweimal facebook
entscheidungen ganz kurzfristig kam
heute morgen rein das
bundesverfassungsgericht dass renate
künast recht gegeben habe zum thema ich
sag mal beschimpfungen auf facebook und
alles was damit zusammenhängt
und dann gab es in der letzten woche
eine wichtige entscheidungen ebenfalls
vom vom bundesgerichtshof zu sogenannten
klarnamen schlicht bei facebook die
allermeisten von euch da draußen die
nicht unter ihrem richtigen namen bei
facebook registriert sind können sich
freuen das kann zu bleiben und dann die
berliner hast du noch uns ein
wunderschönes gerechtes urteil
mitgebracht das herz war auch was mit
corona zu tun aber irgendwie auch mit
dem datum heute denn heute ist der
zweite zweite 22 und damit ein
wahnsinnig beliebt attac zum heiler und
wir haben ein schönes gerechtes urteil
für euch genau ich kenne frau die hat
wird zwei jahren also auf 22 zwillinge
auf die welt auch hinreißen vielleicht
passiert sicherlich heute
auch und das waren nicht irgendwie
kaiserschnitt oder so sondern
tatsächlich natürlich also
soviel zum aufheitern in diese in berlin
wieder wahnsinnig trüben park ja auch
ich weiß nicht ob es irgendwo in
deutschland gerade nicht trüben ja aber
es wird besser die tage menschen wieder
länger und wir jetzt halten wir uns auf
mit den montagsspaziergängen ein fall in
freiburg montagsspaziergänge sind ja die
spaziergänge der jetzt muss ich auch
dass ich sage sehr heterogenen gruppe
der korona leugner
impfkritiker skeptiker und natürlich
aber auch rechtsextremisten und allen
die sich an der korona politik der
bundesregierung stören also eine sehr
gemischte gruppe die sich da versammelt
und nicht zufällig am montag durch die
straßen zieht sondern sehr bewusst der
verfassungsschutz spricht davon dass es
eine kontinuität gibt von den p guida
demonstrationen und natürlich den
montagsdemonstrationen in der zu ende
gehenden ddr genau die heißen dich
überall montagsspaziergänge aber schon
in sehr vielen stücken und das dürfte
darauf zurückgehen genommen sie finden
halt am montag statt früher waren die
demonstration ja er am wochenende die
haben sie jetzt auf den montag verlagert
und ja man geht davon aus dass es eben
sehr bewusst geschehen ist und dabei
sind das doch alles spontane
demonstrationen helene das nicht so hohe
kiste also diese spaziergänge werden
nicht als versammlungen angemeldet weil
sie jeweils als spontan deklariert
werden und eine versammlung die man
spontan stattfindet muss nicht
angemeldet werden so passiert das dann
auch bei diesen spaziergängen und weil
da natürlich ich sage es jetzt mal
einfach vorsichtig erfahrungsgemäß schon
in vielen kommunen das nicht so richtig
funktioniert hat mit der einhaltung der
infektionsschutz rechtlichen vorgaben
also masken abstände usw
greifen die kommunen jetzt mittlerweile
in ihrer verzweiflung zu generellen
verboten also die werden sagen einfach
per allgemeinverfügung von bis darf sich
hier kein mensch versammeln in einem
gebiet iks so das ist natürlich erst mal
mit der versammlungsfreiheit so ein
bisschen ein thema wir haben das schon
besprochen vorerst wenigen wochen
nämlich in der folge 192 am 12 januar
und jetzt hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht aber
entschieden ob das denn wohl so in
ordnung geht und zwar nur im rahmen
einer einstweiligen anordnung und zwar
hat es den antrag eines bürgers gegen
das verbot von montagsspaziergängen
zurückgewiesen also auf deutsch gesagt
die kommune darf diese
montagsspaziergänge in freiburg
weiterhin noch mal kurz aus spontanität
der clou an der sache ist ja aber dass
sie sagen ist sei spontan in wahrheit
aber sich natürlich auch telegramm
gruppen schon tage im voraus
verabschieden also das ist doch eine
umgehung eigentlich dieser möglichkeit
sich spontan zu versammeln das ist eine
ganz klare umgehung das ist auch echt
jetzt ganz ehrlich habe das auch in der
letzten folge schon gesagt im besten
fall bauernschlau und ungefähr so wenig
amüsiert gibt sich dazu jetzt auch das
bundesverfassungsgericht also das kommt
auch in dieser entscheidung durchaus vor
man muss vielleicht einmal irgendwie
sagen dass es jetzt erstmal nichts
ungewöhnlich ist dass eine einstweilige
anordnung nicht erlassen wird das ist
immer ein relativ schwieriger
prüfungsmaßstab und wenn jetzt nicht
total auf der hand liegt dass die
verfassungsbeschwerde jeder dazu gehört
die aber erst im hauptsacheverfahren
viel später entschieden wird
quasi entweder total begründet oder
total unbegründet ist dann guckt sich
das bundesverfassungsgericht einfach die
folgen an und sagt irgendwie naja wenn
es jetzt nicht klar ist wie die
hauptsache ausgeht dann schauen wir uns
an was passieren würde wenn wir jetzt
die einstweilige anordnung erlassen und
nachher würde sich herausstellen dass
sie zu unrecht erlassen worden ist oder
wenn wir sie halt nicht erlassen und
nachher würde sich herausstellen dass er
war eigentlich begründet gewesen ja so
und jetzt sagt das
bundesverfassungsgericht es ist eine
verfassungsrechtlich offene frage die im
hauptsacheverfahren geklärt werden muss
ob es unter bestimmten voraussetzungen
mit der versammlungsfreiheit vereinbar
sein kann präventiv versammlungen durch
allgemeinverfügung zu verbieten die mit
solchen aufrufen zum
montagsspaziergängen zusammenhängen das
heißt alles zu kompliziert um 1 2 gegen
rechtsschutz zu machen ist also
verfassungsrechtlich offen man guckt
sich das gericht an wie wäre es denn
jetzt wenn wir die versammlung werden
wir das verbot aufheben würden oder wie
es wenn wir das nicht aufheben würden
und das
bundesverfassungsgericht sagt jetzt hier
sehr deutlich dass die annahme der
gerichte und behörden dass diese
spaziergänge nicht angemeldet werden um
mögliche auflagen zu umgehen also um zu
vermeiden dass zum beispiel die behörden
sagen ja ihr dürft das machen aber ihr
dürft zum beispiel nur an einem ort
bleiben ihr müsst abständen von zwei
metern einhalten ihr müsst ordner
bestellen die euch die sich darum
kümmern dass diese ganzen vorgaben
eingehalten werden und so dass das mit
absicht umgangen wird eben dadurch dass
man sagt das ist ja hier alles super
spontan und das konnten wir gar nicht
anmelden so das heißt das
bundesverfassungsgericht sagt eigentlich
sehr deutlich dass es jetzt nicht
besonders fernliegend dass die gerichte
davon ausgehen und die behörden sondern
sie sagen sogar dass liegt relativ nahen
und die gerichte dürften auch das sagt
das bundesverfassungsgericht auch sehr
deutlich sich auf die erfahrungen aus
zwei vergangenen sogenannten
spaziergängen auch in freiburg stützen
und sagen wir dürfen davon ausgehen dass
weil ihr ja gegen die korona maßnahmen
demonstrierte die korona maßnahmen auch
nicht einhalten werden so und deswegen
sagt jetzt das bundesverfassungsgericht
jo artikel 8 ist ein super wichtiges
grundrecht und so weiter aber hier gibt
es trotzdem keine einstweilige anordnung
denn wenn der spaziergang nicht
stattfinden darf sich aber nachher in
der verfassungsbeschwerde sind der
hauptsache herausstellen würde dass er
etwa stattfinden müssen dann werde der
beschwerdeführer in seinem grundrecht
auf versammlungsfreiheit verletzt das
ist zwar nicht schön aber es ist nicht
so schlimm wie die tatsache dass wenn
jetzt irgendwie dass das alles
stattfindet und sich dann womöglich
irgendwie menschen anstecken und so
weiter dann das wäre halt einfach
wesentlich schlimmer und deswegen sagt
das bundesverfassungsgericht keine
einstweilige anordnung
und sagt auch noch so gibt auch schon
noch seinen letzten kick mit und sagt
wir haben dabei ausdrücklich zu lasten
des beschwerdeführers berücksichtigt
dass diese menschen ganz bewusst diese
diese versammlungen als spaziergang so
genannten ausgestalten und damit halt
diese vorfeld kooperation mit behörden
unmöglich machen denn da sagt das
bundesverfassungsgericht ihr dürft das
ganze jetzt nicht nicht machen weil hier
die behörden so gemein zu euch sind
sondern ihr könnt ihr das sehr wohl
durchführen wenn ihr mit den behörden
zusammenarbeiten würde und darauf wert
legen würde das dann eben die
gesetzlichen vorgaben oder die
behördlichen auflagen eingehalten werden
und dass zerschießt ihr euch hier gerade
selber und das ganz bewusst so und das
passt sich ja eigentlich wunderbar einen
die ganze rechtsprechung zwei titel acht
die wir kennen nämlich dass
demonstrationen versammlung in
deutschland ja nicht genehmigt werden
müssen sondern nur angemeldet werden
müssen also gibt einfach nur eine es
gibt keine prüfung im vorfeld aber es
gibt eben die anmeldung und die dient
genau diesem ziel dass nämlich die
behörden vorher schauen ob sie
irgendwelche also zum einen werde
ansprechpartner ist bei der versammlung
zweitens ob es irgendwelche maßnahmen
geben muss die flankierend gemacht
werden als schutz der versammlung sind
mit gegendemonstrationen zu rechnen und
all diese dinge auf die sich die
sicherheitsbehörden einstellen müssen
und das ist ja die sogenannte vorfeld
kooperation also dass man kurz bespricht
wie viele leute kommen werden vielleicht
kommen und so weiter alle diese gedanken
um dann auch so eine versammlung
durchführen zu können und die spontanen
versammlung ist wirklich nur für den
fall gedacht dass man das vorher
überhaupt nicht wusste und in einer
situation in der irgendetwas passiert es
sich spontan auf die straße geht und
versammelt wo das halt nicht möglich ist
vorher zu kooperieren und das ist eben
einen finde ich entscheidender punkt
dass sie hier sagen also wäre das so
umgeht das lassen wir uns dann eben
schlichtweg nicht gefallen die offene
frage ist ja jedenfalls habe ich es so
verstanden noch ob man überhaupt per
allgemeinverfügung
versammlungen verbieten kann genau das
sagt das bundesverfassungsgericht aber
auch wie bereits mehrere
verwaltungsgerichtshöfe auch schon
gesagt haben das ist irgendwie so
komplex dass können wir uns im verfahren
schlicht nicht akku na das ist zu
kompliziert und deshalb wird das erst in
der hauptsache entschieden werden ich
glaube dass jetzt auch wahrscheinlich
ein lautes sollten dadurch die republik
geht und wahrscheinlich sehr viele
menschen sagen klar das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat ja auch
alle staatlichen kokona maßnahmen bisher
gehalten und ist fast alles mit gegangen
und so aber aus meiner sicht ist das
durchaus eine wehrhafte entscheidung
auch aus demokratischer sicht denn man
kann ja schon sagen dass das bestenfalls
bauernschlau ist diese diese dieser
ausnahme nutzen zu wollen um
versammlungen einfach komplett ohne
irgendeine vorgabe durchführen zu können
da muss finde ich muss ich ja das muss
sich der staat einfach nicht gefallen
lassen das ist durchaus finde ich eine
wehrhafte entscheidung ja also sich auf
der nase herumtanzen lassen ist immerhin
nicht ratsam aber wie gesagt nur ein
zwei ligen ordnung warten wir mal ab was
in der hauptsache daraus werden haben
wir weiter im auge kommen wir zum
zweiten thema über das ja corinna und
patrick bahners vergangene woche schon
mal gesprochen haben ein thema das mehr
oder weniger dass fast jeder talkshow im
land diskutiert wird wahrscheinlich auch
an vielen abend russischen die
impfpflicht in der vergangenen woche die
sogenannte orientierungs debatte im
bundestag und zwar ungefähr zu der zeit
als ihr den podcast aufgenommen habt
oder genau deswegen hatten wir auch dazu
nichts aufgenommen und wir wussten ja
dass ich diese woche hier mit dir
aufzeichnen und dass du ganz bestimmt
dort bist wir wollten doch jetzt
zumindest mal die gelegenheit ergreifen
dass du uns ein paar impressionen mit
gips wie war es war es eine sternstunde
des bundestags ich muss ehrlich sagen
war es leider nicht ich habe schon
wirklich tolle debatten zu diesen
medizin ethischen fragen also
sterbehilfe auch organspende gesehen wo
abgeordnete sehr persönlich berichtet
hatten aus von ihren eigenen erfahrungen
und ihren persönlichen blick auf das
thema die impfpflicht debatte war ein
austausch von bekannten positionen von
bekannten argumenten auch es ging
eigentlich überhaupt nicht um
persönliche geschichten oder die
persönliche einstellung zu dieser frage
sondern es ging wirklich einerseits um
rechtliche aspekte andererseits um
medizinische es ging natürlich auch um
die vielen ungeklärten fragen die das
die diskussion um die impfpflicht ja so
schwierig machen also wenn wir alle
wissen die impfpflicht helfen hilft
nichts gegen die omikron welle haben wir
allerlei unsicherheiten auf dem tisch
also wenn jetzt jemand geimpft wird ist
er dann im herbst hat dann noch wie hoch
es dann noch seine immunität schützt es
dann gegen eine künftige variante von
der wir noch gar nichts wissen
wie ist es mit dem laufen wieder in ein
riesiges vollzugsdefizit rein also wie
bekommt man die leute dazu wirklich sich
impfen zu lassen
wie groß ist die der wille zur befolgung
dieser pflicht was macht man wenn sie
nicht freiwillig befolgt wird und so
weiter also das wurde alles diskutiert
aber keine total neuen aspekte und da
niemand auch die abgeordneten nicht in
die zukunft blicken können lieben diese
fragen eben auch offen und es war eben
schon auch ein schlagabtausch zwischen
regierung und opposition was es ja
eigentlich gerade nicht sein sollte aber
die cdu csu fraktion hat sich ja nicht
damit abgefunden dass die
bundesregierung keinen regierungsentwurf
vorliegt sondern auf diesem verfahren
der fraktionsübergreifenden anträge
besteht in klammern vor allem deshalb
weil sie keine eigene mehrheit hat weil
viele abgeordnete
eben keine allgemeine impfpflicht
befürworten klammer zu so und deswegen
die union hat im grunde genommen sich in
ihren redebeiträgen mehr oder weniger
darin erschöpft der bundesregierung
vorzuwerfen dass sie keinen jährigen die
regierungs im gesetzentwurf vorgelegt
hat das ist auf eine anfrage mit lauter
einzelfragen also ich glaube 23 an der
zahl die die unions fraktion gestellt
hatte noch erst keine und dann eine
unbefriedigende antwort gab also es war
eine anklage wenn man so will oder ein
ja beschwerde zu vernehmen aus den
reihen der cdu csu fraktion aber relativ
wenig in der sache außer dass sie für
ein im register sind und die aus den
ampel fraktionen
kamen diverse redebeiträge die ein
dieser drei entwürfe jemals
befürworteten also das ist ja auch
mittlerweile glaube ich bekannt es gibt
die allgemeine impfpflicht ab 18 die
eine gruppe um jana stammen und wie sie
befürworte dann gibt es diese vermitteln
der auffassung in pflicht ab 50 eben für
die besonders gefährdeten wir besonders
wohl nach haben gruppen die also die
älteren besonders unter corona leiden
und schwere verläufe zu befürchten sind
und die gruppe um kubicki die gegen eine
impfpflicht insgesamt sind und es war
wer sich noch nicht mit dem thema
beschäftigt hat natürlich erhellend ich
weiß nicht und das ist so die frage die
ich habe wer eigentlich da
von den abgeordneten
wirklich was dazu gelernt hat so
insofern kann man diese ich hatte
sowieso schon zweifel an diesen
verfahren und die wurden jetzt nicht
ausgeräumt durch diese debatte am ende
meldete sich noch karl lauterbach sprach
aber nicht als gesundheitsminister
sondern als abgeordneter
und hat eine sehr philosophische rede
gehalten hegel zitiert und so weiter und
sehr ja dann geworben für die allgemeine
impfpflicht sein haus sagt ja er sie
unter ist unterstützt alle
gruppen dabei sind gesetzentwurf
auszuarbeiten denn das ist ja alles
andere als einfach also so eckpunkte zu
formulieren wie das wohl aussehen soll
ist das eine und das dann wirklich
aufzuschreiben mit einer entsprechenden
begründung die dann auch so gut ist dass
sie bei all diesen offenen fragen vor
dem verfassungsgericht hält ist wirklich
eine ganz andere sache und da braucht
man gute juristen und übrigens davon
gibt es im bundesgesundheitsministerium
noch nicht mal sonderlich viele soweit
ich weiß gibt es ja nur zwei referate
die sich wirklich mit rechtsfragen im
engeren sinne beschäftigen weshalb in
der ersten phase der pandemie viele
verordnungen nicht nur vom
gesundheitsministerium sondern mit dem
innenministerium zusammen erarbeitet
wurden weil die halt viel mehr manpower
haben was auch juristischen sachverstand
angeht also da kommt auch auf die
ministerien noch wann geht es da noch
ein jahr das dauert ja genau das gehört
noch ein bisschen jetzt haben wir ja im
februar überhaupt nur eine sitzungswoche
wegen karneval in klammern der ja gar
nicht stattfindet also auch ein bisschen
absurd und dann also das ganze wird so
oder so sich noch mindestens bis zum
sommer hinziehen wenn es denn überhaupt
ja ich glaube mein vater auch noch was
sich bei den wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen tut jetzt haben wir schon
gesehen was ist bei der einrichtungs
bezogen impfpflicht für probleme gibt
also das ist da schon bei den fragen wie
setzt man überhaupt durch und ist dann
überhaupt noch das pflegepersonal
genügend vorhanden wer sich jetzt die
diskussion die soll eigentlich ab dem 16
mehr herz gelten und das ministerium hat
ja jetzt wohl schon gesagt dass auch
ungeimpfte dann erstmal weiter arbeiten
gehen können korrekt ja also jedenfalls
ist das im eine debatte die jetzt
anfängt für berlin hat das franziska
giffey auch so gesagt das sind alles
sind wirklich alles noch offene fragen
also es gab ja sogar jetzt den vorstoß
ob infizierte ohne symptome noch eine
rolle spielen sollen bei der versorgung
bei bestimmten kritischen
infrastrukturen also es ist wirklich
eine sehr diffuse lage jetzt und ich
glaube viele sagen wir müssen jetzt den
peak der mikrowelle abwarten schauen wie
sich die lage in den krankenhäusern
insbesondere auf den intensivstationen
entwickelt und dann entscheiden ob das
wirklich der richtige weg ist also auch
abgeordnete die ich bin sehr gespannt
wie das wohl laufen wird wenn wir dann
gleichzeitig über die impfpflicht
debattieren und über lockerungen aller
ort sehr sehr land habe den an und da
geht derzeit passiert so viel
gleichzeitig ist es auch gar nicht kein
vorwurf sondern es ist einfach eine sehr
unübersichtliche lage und meinen
natürlich nicht maßgeblich erhöht und
trotzdem hat meine meinung ist dass man
in so einer ja in seiner chaotischen
situation vielleicht nicht so eine
einschneidende maßnahme wie die
impfpflicht beschließen sollte wenn wir
dann in drei monaten feststellen es ist
doch wieder alles ganz anders aber ich
weiss dazu gibt es diverse meinung und
wir werden darauf schauen wie es
weitergeht und kommen jetzt zu
wesentlich fassbaren themen genau ja
jetzt kommen wir zu sehr handfesten
themen auch wo es uns wirklich ums geld
geht betriebsschließung etliche
geschäfte restaurants mussten ja durch
regelungen infektionsschutzgesetz und
verordnung der
landesregierungen über wochen und monate
schließen und haben natürlich
wahnsinnige einbußen trotz der hilfen
die es gegeben hat und jetzt ist die
frage zahlt die versicherung eigentlich
genau und der bgh hat in der vergangenen
woche zugunsten des kölner versicherers
axa entschieden dass die
betriebsschließung versicherung für
diesen fall nicht zahlen musste es ging
darum einen gastronomen aus schleswig
holstein
der wollte verdienstausfall für 30 tage
lockdown im märz 2020 haben man kann
sich jetzt mal überlegen die
betriebsschließung versicherung das ist
doch wohl genau der fall für den ich
sozusagen meine versicherung
abgeschlossen aber eine
betriebsschließung versicherung die
zahlt nämlich dann wenn vermögensschäden
einem betrieb dadurch entstehen dass das
unternehmen vom staat geschlossen wird
wegen einer krankheit
die ansteckend ist so also wenn der
staat den betrieb wegen einer krankheit
dicht gemacht haben sich dann irgendwie
alle unternehmer diese vorsichtig waren
eine betriebsschließung versicherung
abzuschließen mit acht mensch habe ich
ja noch mal glück gehabt dann kriege ich
wenigstens geld von der versicherung das
war leider nicht so und zwar von anfang
an war das auch relativ umstritten die
versicherer das natürlich von anfang an
sehr anders gesehen als die versicherten
das argument war immer so ein bisschen
ja gut wenn wir gewusst hätten dass
corona kommt dann hätten wir solche
versicherungen überhaupt nicht angeboten
das ist ja alles viel viel viel zu teuer
es gab dann versicherer die sich relativ
kulant gezeigt haben die angeboten haben
teilweise zu zahlen und so also viele
unternehmen an sich damit dem
versicherer auch geeinigt aber es gab
eben auch welche die das komplett
verweigert haben und gesagt haben wir
gegen das durch die instanzen natürlich
jeweils unter verweis auf ihre
versicherungsbedingungen und um genau
die ging es jetzt auch vor dem bgh wie
gesagt das war die achse hier aus köln
und da der bgh senat der senat für
versicherungs sachen gesagt mit der
klausel die die axa in ihren bedingungen
hatte gibt es jedenfalls für einen cupid
19 bedingten ausfall in der pandemie nix
ich versuche das jetzt einigermaßen so
zusammenzufassen dass man das verstehen
kann in den bedingungen ist der
versicherungsfall definiert als wenn die
zuständige behörde auf grundlage des
infektionsschutzgesetzes das kennen wir
jetzt alle mittlerweile relativ gut beim
auftreten meldepflichtige krankheiten
den versicherten betrieb zur
verhinderung der verbreitung von
meldepflichtigen krankheiten schließt so
und dieses auftreten meldepflichtige
krankheiten der stand aber dahinter
siehe nummer zwei und unter dieser
nummer zwei folgte dann ein katalog der
bestimmte krankheiten auflistete und
stand oben drüber das sind die folgenden
im infektion schutzgesetz in den
paragraphen sechs und sieben namentlich
genannten krankheiten dann kam aber ein
eigener katalog und da stand natürlich
corona nicht drin weil als dieser
versicherungsvertrag abgeschlossen wurde
gab es ja kein cola das kannte also kein
mensch der bgh hat jetzt gesagt diese
klausel erfassen betriebsschließungen
die die verbreitung von corona
verhindern sollen aber nicht denn in den
agb dieser versicherung hätte die achse
eben eine eigene definition vorgenommen
der krankheiten und erika bei denen eine
schließung den versicherungsfall auslöst
und dieser katalog wo eben dann keine
ahnung zehn krankheiten drin standen
aufgrund derer der stadt schließen kann
der sei abschließend nach dem
maßgeblichen verständnis des
durchschnittlichen versicherungsnehmers
die uranerz da draußen kennen das
aber moment mal ist das nicht irgendwie
ganz merkwürdig dass man
zu einer zeit in der noch niemand was
von kogit wusste hätte man sich ja dann
überhaupt gar nicht dagegen versichern
können ist mal muss man nicht solche
kataloge würde ich jetzt mal eine andere
rechtsauffassung vertreten so lesen dass
diese krankheiten und ähnliche davon
erfasst sind also ich bin bei dir und
das war natürlich so oder so ähnlich war
natürlich auch die argumentation der der
betriebe die ja da auch natürlich sich
durch alle instanzen geklagt haben ich
halte diese entscheidung des bgh
durchaus für vertretbar aber auch nicht
für zwingend denn du hast total recht
das steht sogar ein verweist darin auf
die paragrafen 6 und 7
infektionsschutzgesetz und als corona
dann aufgetreten ist wurde corinna
natürlich auch aufgenommen ins
infektionsschutzgesetz aber da hat der
bgh hat gesagt das versteht ja
durchschnittliche versicherungsnehmer
nur als klarstellung dass der
versicherer sich bei der formulierung
seiner eigenen klausel und seines
eigenen krankheiten katalogs für den
erhofften will quasi an den vorschriften
des infektions gesetze schutz gesetzes
orientiert habe und wer hat jetzt also
da können sich natürlich erstmal die
versicherer freuen und die versicherten
blicken in die röhre aber gibt es denn
also wann hat man denn als unternehmen
die chance trotzdem geld zu bekommen
genau also das wurde jetzt letzte woche
natürlich ein bisschen gefeiert als
grundsatzentscheidung aus sicht der
versicherer sicherlich auch
nachvollziehbar dass als solche zu
feiern das ist es aber nicht sondern
eher wie er hat jetzt eben für diesen
einen fall und für diese eine klausel
sagt da gibt es kein geld
das heißt nicht dass es für niemanden
geld gibt sondern das heißt eigentlich
nur dass man einen sehr klaren blick ins
kleingedruckte werfen sollte nämlich in
die versicherungsbedingungen denn der
bgh hat auch klar gestellt dass es
keineswegs so ist das betriebsschließung
versicherung nie für corona schließungen
zahlen müssten das wurde am anfang auch
mal diskutiert ob das nicht überhaupt
nur für für fälle in betracht kommt wo
der betrieb geschlossen wird quasi aus
einer wegen der gefahr die aus dem
eigenen betrieb raus kommt also was weiß
ich deine schweine haben die
schweinepest oder so deswegen machen wir
dir jetzt dicht als behörde grad der bgh
gesagt nee nee nee also auch solche
dinge wie wie corona auch eine alle
werden geschlossen völlig unabhängig von
dem eigenen betrieb das kann schon auch
ein versicherungsfall auslösen es darf
aber eben nicht so eine abschließende
klausel drin sein in der korona nicht
drin steht also alle die eine offenere
klausel haben oder vielleicht sogar nur
ein verweis auf infektionsschutzgesetz
die könnten damit durchaus noch weiter
kommen also da ist noch nicht alles
verloren okay da geht es ja nämlich
tatsächlich um wahrscheinlich
zehntausende pro
woche oder im jahr da kann es schon um
richtig viel geld gehen das ist halt der
volle ertragsausfall also unter nicht
dass es meistens begrenzt ich glaube auf
so nen monat oder so aber immerhin ein
kompletter monat umsatzausfall oder so
das ist ja schon echt richtig viel geld
sonja unternehmen also ein klassischer
fall von es kommt darauf an irgendwie
vom bgh in diesem fall dann aufs
kleingedruckte
okay na dann wünschen wir allen
betrieben
wenn man es jetzt mal auf der einen
seite stellen weil gute klausel
genau und kommt damit zum schwerpunkt
eline ja genau der guten stimmung in
eine betroffene hier ich weiß ist du in
mancherlei hinsicht anders denkt als ich
wir können das bei gelegenheit auch mal
diskutieren auch dieses thema bleibt uns
erhalten
zugeschaltet ist uns nun kirsten kubat
gonther grünen abgeordnete im bundestag
stellvertretende vorsitzende des
gesundheitsausschusses und aufgrund der
umstände die ja allgemein bekannt sind
führt sie derzeit tatsächlich sitzung
leitet den ausschuss weil es ja keinen
ausschussvorsitzenden gibt herzlich
willkommen frau kate konnte
guten morgen
wir wollen heute sprechen wie ich gerade
schon angekündigt hatte über ein
gesetzentwurf zur
suizidbeihilfe
der vergangenen donnerstag vorgestellt
wurde von einer gruppe von abgeordneten
es handelt sich auch hier wieder um
einen fraktionsübergreifenden
antrag der also nicht von der
bundesregierung vorgebracht wird sondern
aus der mitte des bundestags wie das ja
bei medizin ethischen fragen üblich ist
und in der vergangenheit auch schon so
war wir wollen uns heute mit frau katka
über diesen gesetzentwurf unterhalten
die schwierigkeiten die es dabei gibt
was ist eigentlich das
selbstbestimmungsrecht das recht auf
einen selbstbestimmten tod und wie kann
man diese selbstbestimmung schützen
schön dass sie zeit haben für unsere
konter sie sind ja nicht nur
bundestagsabgeordnete und grünen
politikerin sondern auch fachärztin für
psychiatrie und psychotherapie und
deswegen natürlich mit all diesen fragen
rund um das thema sehr vertraut
vielleicht beginnen wir einfach mal mit
dem gesetzentwurf
sie wollen suizidbeihilfe unter strengen
voraussetzungen
erlauben sagen sie uns doch mal was drin
steht unter welchen voraussetzungen man
ein sterbewillige denn suizidbeihilfe in
anspruch nehmen können soll
ja es ist genauso wie sie gesagt haben
frau kowski dass es ein
interfraktioneller gesetzentwurf den wir
von abgeordneten aus allen
demokratischen fraktionen erarbeitet
haben und vorgestellt haben und der kern
ist die suizidbeihilfe zu ermöglichen
aber eben nicht zu fördern das heißt
unter bestimmten umständen soll es
möglich werden dass suizidbeihilfe in
anspruch genommen wird aber
gleichzeitig wird ein schutzkonzept
etabliert was sicherstellt dass die
selbstbestimmung der radium
suizidbeihilfe ersuchen auch wirklich
gesichert ist und
das schutzkonzept besteht aus
psychiatrischen untersuchungen und
beratung habe ich das richtig verstanden
genau ist es so dass wir wissen dass
suizidalität ja etwas ist was in der
regel sehr volatil ist und immer an
kontext der alltagsbedingungen der
lebensumstände geknüpft ist und es muss
eben sichergestellt werden dass eine
person die suizidbeihilfe in anspruch
nehmen möchte wirklich frei ist von
inneren und äußeren druck situationen
die diese suizid wunsch möglicherweise
gefördert und um das sicherzustellen
dass es sich wirklich um eine ganz frei
verantwortlichen schaltung handelt sieht
unser schutzkonzept vor zwei sichert
rische untersuchungen im abstand von
drei monaten und
zusätzlich die möglichkeit von
beratungsangeboten
wie beispielsweise psychotherapie aber
auch schuldenberatung andere
beratungsmöglichkeiten weil wir wissen
dass
suizidalität eben auch folge sagen kann
von einsamkeit von armut von der sorge
jemanden zur last zu fallen und das muss
man natürlich vorher ausschließen bevor
es mit hilfe dann in anspruch genommen
werden kann und wirklich sicherzustellen
dass es sich hier um einen
selbstbestimmten willen handelt für
schwerstkranke die sehr schwer
körperlich krank sind ist vorgesehen
dass eine einzige untersuchung
ausreichen soll und dann auch innerhalb
von zwei wochen die suizidbeihilfe in
anspruch genommen werden kann wie gehen
sie denn mit dem thema depression um
also können grundsätzlich auch
depressive patienten suizidbeihilfe in
anspruch nehmen ist das auch eine
schwere krankheit oder meinen sie
geht es nur bei körperlichen schweren
erkrankungen die tatsächlich zum tode
führen
dass die allermeisten
suizid impulse tatsächlich im
zusammenhang mit psychischen
erkrankungen sich entwickeln und vor
allem im zusammenhang mit der depression
es ist nicht so dass jede depressive
person diesen willen nicht
freiverantwortlich bilden kann das wäre
dann eben aufgabe der untersuchen das
herauszufinden aber grundsätzlich ist es
natürlich so dass es
wünschenswert ist ist eine person die
aufgrund einer depressivität ein suizid
wunsch entwickelt und da müssen wir
vielleicht einmal kurz einfügen ein
suizid wunsch ist in der regel nicht der
wunsch nach dem tod sondern der wunsch
nach einer pause nach einer zäsur von
einer als unerträglich empfunden
lebenssituation und das ist eben bei
menschen mit depressiven erkrankungen
häufig der fall darum ist es so wichtig
festzustellen ob dieser suizid impuls
der depressivität folgt oder ob es eine
depression gibt und gleichzeitig einen
freiverantwortlich gewählten willens
suizid assistenz in anspruch zu nehmen
diese sonderregelung auf die sie da
ansprechen ohne eine untersuchung
ausreichen soll und dann sehr
kurzfristig auch die suizid assistenz in
anspruch genommen werden sollte ist
vorgesehen für schwere körperliche
ohnehin zum tode führende erkrankung
und die suizidbeihilfe soll dann
durchgeführten praktiziert werden von
ärzten ist das richtig und bleibt da da
gab es ja auch die sorge bei ärzten in
der vergangenheit von so einem jahr von
einer rechtlichen grauzone dass sie sich
gegebenenfalls eben doch strafbar machen
ist es ausgeräumt
aktuell ist ja die situation dass wir
nachdem karlsruhe geurteilt hat dass der
alte 217 verfassungswidrig ist haben wir
ja eine situation wo sie zieht beihilfe
geleistet wird insbesondere von
entsprechenden sogenannten sterbehilfen
vereinen ohne dass es dafür ein also
dass es eingebettet ist in ein regelwerk
und oder in ein schutzkonzept was unser
vorschlag ist dass sowohl sterbehilfe
vereine als auch ärztinnen und ärzte
diese
suizid beihilfe leisten dürfen wenn sie
eben sicherstellen wenn sichergestellt
ist dass diese schutzkonzept über das
leben gesprochen haben auch angewendet
wird die ms und tödliche
betäubungsmittel geht die zum zur
suizidbeihilfe angewendet werden sollen
dann müssen die zwingend ärztlich
verordnet werden nach unserer
vorstellung in dem moment der ge
sterbens ist es aber nicht erforderlich
dass ein arzt oder eine ärztin
und wenn die beratungspflichten nicht
eingehalten werden dann bleibt der raum
für das strafrecht da sehen sie eine
strafandrohung von bis zu drei jahren
vor für diejenigen die den die
suizidbeihilfe durchführen ganz genau
also der die regeln dieses ganze
diese ganzen schutzkonzepte über die wir
gerade gesprochen haben im strafrecht
und wenn die nicht eingehalten werden
dann
greift eben auch das strafrecht es gibt
eine sondersituation und die ist wenn
ein arzt oder eine ärztin im rahmen
einer langjährigen behandlung grund und
damit einer besonderen nähe zur
patientin zum patienten
sterbehilfe
durchführt dann greift nicht dieses
regelwerk über das wir gerade gesprochen
haben sondern das ist eine
sondersituation worüber wir sprechen und
was wir in diesem gesetzentwurf regeln
ist wenn wiederholt suizidbeihilfe
angeboten wird sie haben gerade schon
das karlsruher urteil ist im februar
2020 angesprochen wir blicken jetzt mal
zurück die ganze
neuregelung ist ja durch dieses urteil
notwendig geworden 2015 hatte sich der
bundestag auch damals mit
fraktionsübergreifenden anträgen also
eine breite meinung nun hat
stattgefunden mit vier anträgen die es
damals gab und der antrag der sich dann
durchgesetzt hatte ist der
217 stgb in dem eben die geschäftsmäßige
sterbehilfe unter strafe steht
geschäftsmäßig nur zur erinnerung ist
anders als gewerbsmäßig nicht notwendig
mit gewinnerzielungsabsicht sondern ist
lediglich auf wiederholung angelegtes
tun das hat man damals unter strafe
gestellt aber das verfassungsgericht hat
eben 2020 auf verfassungsbeschwerden
unter anderem von diesen sterbehilfe
vereinen hin die regelung für
verfassungswidrig
erklärt mit dem argument
das recht auf selbstbestimmtes sterben
beinhaltet nicht nur das recht aus dem
leben zu scheiden sondern sich damit
auch hilfe zu nehmen und so argument
ruhe weiter mit dieser unter strafe
stellung von der arbeit von sterbehilfe
vereinen würden den menschen eigentlich
die möglichkeiten genommen sich hilfe zu
holen beim selbstbestimmten sterben als
man damals die entscheidung gelesen
hatte hatte jedenfalls ich den eindruck
was bleibt da eigentlich überhaupt für
einen raum für den gesetzgeber also dass
dieses das recht auf selbstbestimmtes
sterben dass das verfassungsgericht aus
den artikeln 1 und 2 des grundgesetzes
herleitet war so absolut gestellt dass
man dachte eigentlich gibt es gar keinen
raum zur einschränkung von kappa konnte
sie haben jetzt aber ein gesetzentwurf
gemacht der dieses der das anders sieht
vielleicht sagen sie uns mal welchen
raum hat ihrer meinung nach karlsruhe
dem gesetzgeber gelassen
er karlsruhe hatte in diesem sehr
umfassenden urteil für eine
komplexe situation im wesentlichen zwei
leitplanken definiert das eine ist es
muss der zugang also zum assistierten
suizid für menschen die diesen wellen
frei gebildet haben selbständig am
selbstbestimmt gebildet haben
ermöglichen und zum 2 karlsruhe aber
auch der gesetzgeber darf ein
schutzkonzept für
wo nabu gruppen entwickeln damit
sichergestellt ist dass der suizid
wunsch wirklich dem freien willen folgt
und nicht etwa ausdruck verleihen oder
äußeren drucksituationen ist und genau
in diesen rahmungen in diesen
leitplanken die karlsruhe uns aufgegeben
hat als gesetzgeber bewegt sich dieser
vorschlag den wir hier vorgestellt haben
also einerseits den zugang zu
ermöglichen und andererseits zu
definieren wie sicher gestellt wird dass
der bilder auch wirklich autonom und
selbstbestimmt gefasst wurde und das ist
ja wirklich wichtig wenn wir wissen dass
der wunsch oder oder der der suizid
impuls wie wir eben schon gesprochen
haben ihn immer sich im kontext
entwickelt und immer auch oder oder in
der regel volatil ist also mal mehr
vorhanden sein kann ein wenig dass diese
dieser impuls eben sehr die ihm folgt
wie die lebenssituation ist da muss man
natürlich gucken was sind übliche
faktoren im leben die zu solchen
suizidalen impulsen führen können und
das ist zum einen eben eine psychische
erkrankung
darüber hatten wir eben schon gesprochen
zum anderen aber auch einsamkeit
armut angst vor krankheit angst vor
schmerzen und auch angst vor einer
unzureichenden pflegesituation wenn
personen alt sind und hilfebedürftig
werden oder auch das erleben einer
unzureichenden pflegesituation und wir
müssen natürlich gesetzgeberisch
sicherstellen dass nicht etwa sowie
zieht bei hilfe in anspruch genommen
wird weil auf der anderen seite die
pflegeeinrichtungen haben und ein
inzwischen zunehmenden pflegemangel
haben das sind ja wichtige faktoren wenn
es natürlich sicherstellen dass der
zugang zur psychotherapie leichter ist
als der zugang zum suizid assistenz wir
müssen sicherstellen dass nicht etwa
menschen die aus angst heraus anderen
zur last zu fallen das betrifft im
übrigen häufiger frauen als männer dank
na dann bin ich wohl lieber suizid
assistenz in anspruch nehmen als meine
tochter meinem sohn hier
herein zu bereiten das sind alles sehr
sehr valide gründe um sicherzustellen
dass der gesetzgeber hier eben ein
entsprechendes schutzkonzept auflegt und
das wird karlsruher auch ausdrücklich in
seinem urteil ermöglicht und in diesem
rahmen bewegen wir uns also die idee ist
überhaupt die selbstbestimmung zu
schützen herauszufinden was wirklich die
selbstbestimmung ist und das ist ja das
was karlsruhe
in seiner entscheidung vorangestellt hat
also es ist keine einschränkung der
selbstbestimmung so habe ich sie jetzt
verstanden sondern ist es im gegenteil
die der schutz der selbstbestimmung den
sie anstreben dann ja ganz genau als es
der kern dieses vorschlags den wir
machen ist die selbstbestimmung zu
schützen und das selbst eben voraus dass
sichergestellt ist dass
der impuls der suizidalität über den wir
gesprochen haben der eben in aller regel
der impuls ist so geht es nicht weiter
dass da sichergestellt ist dass es nicht
andere möglichkeiten gibt diesen
impuls richtung suizidalität wieder zu
reduzieren und zu sagen aha wenn ich
gute pflege bekomme wenn ich nicht mehr
angst haben muss dass meine rente nicht
ausreicht wenn ich zugang zur
psychotherapie habe dann kann ich mir
gut vorstellen und dann möchte ich auch
weiter geben das ist ja entscheidend
dass wir diese inneren oder äußeren
drucksituationen die eben zu der
suizidalität führen können
identifizieren und dann gucken lassen
sich diese drucksituationen reduzieren
also die kerne selbstbestimmung unseres
gesetzes aber auch suizidprävention und
darum haben wir ja neben diesen
gesetzentwurf den wir vorgestellt haben
über den wir jetzt schon viel gesprochen
haben auch einen antrag zur verbesserung
der suizidprävention in unserer republik
gleichzeitig vor billig
und der die palliativmedizin ist
natürlich in diesem zusammenhang auch
immer zu erwähnen weil gerade bei
patienten mit starken schmerzen die
deswegen
suizidgedanken haben weil sie es einfach
nicht aushalten da jedenfalls hört man
das aus der forschung tatsächlich noch
mehr drin ist und in der vergangenheit
das können sie als ärztin sicherlich
besser beurteilen als ich aber der
schwerpunkt häufig auf die kreativen
methoden gelegt wurde und nicht so sehr
auf die palliativen und da kann man ja
vielleicht auch noch was tun es stinkt
jetzt bei mir durch dieses thema ist ja
sehr nicht nur sehr emotional sondern
auch ein sehr persönlich ist deswegen
gibt es ja auch diese offene debatte im
bundestag ich hatte mich auch an anderer
stelle schon mal dazu geäußert ich sehe
das auch bin dabei liberalisierung auch
sehr vorsichtig andere auch kollegen bei
mir hier in der redaktion sehen ist
anders
ja ein schwieriges thema ich blicke
wirklich auch zum beispiel die
rechtslage in belgien ich weiß nicht ob
sie da noch ein paar worte zu sagen
wollen mit einigem unbehagen da wo ja
auch suizidbeihilfe etwa für kinder
möglich ist und also sehr sehr sehr
liberal wo es kaum einschränkungen gibt
wo es aber natürlich auch befürworter
gibt die sagen na ja das ist das zeichen
größter liebe wenn man seine angehörigen
nicht leiden lässt und nicht zwingend am
leben zu bleiben wie sehen sie den blick
insbesondere auf belgien oder aufs
europäische ausland volker barth konnte
ja das eine wirklich ein ganz wichtiger
dass die
häufigkeit des menschen sich sowie
zitieren zu nehmen je besser der zugang
zur suizid mitteln ist desto häufiger
begehen menschen suizid und dann auch
eben final so dass dann auch der tod
volk und das gilt eben einerseits dafür
wenn brücken beispielsweise so gebaut
sind es ist relativ leicht ist runter zu
springen oder hochhäuser
dass das dann die wahrscheinlichkeit
steigt dass menschen sich so deshalb ist
ja so wichtig dass wir auch da im
öffentlichen raum einfach
schutzmechanismen einbauen wie zb
bestimmte geländer höhen und das gleiche
gilt eben offensichtlich auch dafür wenn
assistierter suizid wenn der zugang
besonders leicht gemacht wird dann
steigt die zahl derer die sich so
zitieren und es ist eben nicht so was
manche
denken oder auch offen dass die zahl der
so genannten harten suizide
beispielsweise sich vor ein ic werfen
was natürlich grauenvoll ist gerade auch
für die fahrerinnen und fahrer der ics
dass die zurückgingen wenn man den
zugang zum assistierten suizid
erleichtert sondern es gibt eben in der
summe dann eine entwicklung dass es mehr
assistierte suizid gibt und das führt
dazu dass auch renommierte menschen die
sich in diesen ländern belgien und den
niederlanden früher sehr für eine
öffnung des zugangs ausgesprochen haben
inzwischen da sehr skeptisch sind weil
man eben diese beobachtung machen kann
dass die suizidwillige der der
vollendete sowie zieht dann zunimmt und
bei kindern da sprechen sie etwas sehr
sehr wichtiges an unser vorschlag sieht
vor dass suizid assistenz für kinder und
jugendliche bis 18 ausgeschlossen ist
das halte ich auch für elementar weil
wir wissen dass gerade bei kindern und
jugendlichen suizid impulse relativ
häufig sind gerade in der pubertät ist
etwas was vielleicht viele hörerinnen
und hörer auch aus eigener erfahrung
wissen das ist ja immer mal wieder
kurse gibt die aber dann im kontext eben
auch des lebens sehr schnell wieder
verschwinden können wenn sich die
aktuelle lebenssituation verändert hat
also das ist etwas was unser
gesetzentwurf klar vorsieht dass es hier
ein ausschluss des zugangs zum
assistierten suizid bei kindern und
jugendlichen geht
blickt noch einmal zurück auf die
debatte von 2000 oder vor 2015 also vor
der verabschiedung dieses 217 stgb über
den wir schon gesprochen habe das verbot
der geschäftsmäßigen sterbehilfe da
waren sie ja noch nicht im bundestag es
war aber eine dieser debatten die als
sternstunde in die geschichte des
bundestags ein ging also auch eine sehr
emotionale persönliche debatte da gab es
ja dann einigen unmut dass das
verfassungsgericht
da einschreitet und zwar nicht wegen des
inhalts der entscheidung sondern dass
eine breite meinungsbildung im bundestag
sozusagen von karlsruhe ausgehebelt wird
wie sehen sie das also und befürchten
sie dass das jetzt vielleicht wieder
passiert also dass man das der dass der
spielraum des gesetzgebers da eigentlich
zu eng ist in diesen breiten debatten
zum ergebnis zu kommen das dann eben
nicht hält
wir haben ja gewaltenteilung in unserem
land als grundfeste der demokratie und
des films also
sehr sehr richtig von daher ist es
natürlich so dass gesetze die wir im
bundestag machen
der
verfassungsfest sein müssten und
karlsruhe
hat die aufgabe sich das dann
entsprechend anzugucken und zu
überprüfen und im fall des alten 217 ist
karlsruhe eben zu der ungeschriebenen
entscheidung gekommen
wir gehen davon aus weil wir das urteil
von karlsruhe natürlich sehr sehr genau
studiert haben dass das was wir jetzt
vorlegen sich genau
dann in diesen bahnen bewegt die
karlsruhe uns aufgetragen hat von daher
gehe ich davon aus in unser
gesetzentwurf eine mehrheit bekommen
wird was ich sehr hoffe damit die
selbstbestimmung hier eben wirklich
geschützt wird jeder und jedes einzelnen
dass das dann auch verfassungsrecht sein
wird dann blicken wir doch mal nach
vorne sie haben ja in ihrer
fraktionsübergreifenden gruppe glaube
ich außer der afg vertreter aller
fraktionen und es gab auch schon
unterstützung zb von frau stark
watzinger und hubertus heil also eine
ziemlich man hat den eindruck dass sie
da schon recht breit aufgestellt sind es
gibt aber noch zwei andere
gesetzentwürfe die noch aus der
vergangenen legislatur
in der vergangenen legislatur erarbeitet
wurden und jetzt wieder auf den tisch
liegen wie geht jetzt diese
meinungsbildung im bundestag weiter wird
es da auch eine orientierungs debatte
geben wie jetzt bei der impfpflicht oder
wie mit was auf was müssen wir uns
einstellen das wird jetzt entschieden
also es ist genau so dass es noch zwei
andere gesetzentwürfe gibt die zum einen
den
fordern dass es eine flächendeckende
infrastruktur geben soll für angebote
der suizidbeihilfe da habe ich wirklich
ein ganz große stöhr gefühl wenn ich
denke wir machen staatlicher weise eine
infrastruktur zum zugang zum
assistierten suizid und versäumnis leben
pflegemangel oder den die langen
wartezeiten bei psychotherapie endlich
in den griff zu bekommen
dann kann ich mir nicht gut vorstellen
dass ein solcher und wirklichkeit
findet aber also es wird ich vermute mal
dass diese beiden entwürfe der letzten
legislatur auch wieder eingebracht
werden in den deutschen bundestag und
dann wird sich der ältestenrat darüber
verständigen ob wir diese gesetzentwürfe
direkt debattieren oder ob noch eine
orientierungs debatte vorgeschaltet wird
ich gehöre zu denen die
viel sympathie haben für eine
neuorientierung debatte weil wir eben
sehr viel neue mitglieder des deutschen
bundestags auch haben und es sicher
sinnvoll ist auch gesellschaftlich
diesen
klick nochmal zur verfügung zu stellen
welche verschiedenen positionen im
bundestag vorhanden sind aber dass es
noch nicht endgültig entschieden klar
ist aber für mich dass wir nicht zu
lange warten dürfen um wirklich hier zu
einer einigung im bundestag zu kommen
und zu einem neuen gesetz weil wir jetzt
eben die situation haben dadurch dass
der alte 217 für nichtig erklärt wurde
dass wir eine dass suizid beihilfe
geleistet wird unter anderem auch in
pflegeheimen ohne dass es dafür eben ein
ausreichendes schutzkonzept und das
macht mir wirklich sorgen nämlich der
217 wurde ja beseitigt ohne dass es
irgendeine ersatz gibt es derzeit gelten
überhaupt keine einschränkung für
vereine die suizidbeihilfe leisten und
zwar auch nicht wenn ich es richtig sehe
gewerbsmäßig oder also auch die das
gegen geld tun
absolut also das ist wir haben im moment
da ein
und dass
einer sich der selbstbestimmung gegend
wirklich abträglich weil die vereine die
jetzt zur zeit
assistierten suizid quasi als
dienstleistung anbieten die tun das eben
ohne dass vorher sichergestellt ist dass
die selbstbestimmung wirklich gewagt ist
die tun dass ohne das untersucht worden
ist ob es innere oder äußere
drucksituationen die die zu diesem
impuls führen und das macht mir große
große sorgen weil aus meiner sicht dass
der selbstbestimmung wirklich
entgegenstehen der beginn der winter ist
ja eine zeit die für depressive menschen
besonders schwierig ist der november
sagt man ja es ist so ein monat in dem
ganz viele menschen sich mit oder
diejenigen die dazu neigen der suizid
wunsch besonders starker vortritt ich
weiß nicht ob sich das mit
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen deckt
das ist so ja
ok meinen sie bis dahin gibt es ein
neues gesetz
ich hoffe dass wir im laufe dieses
jahres zu einer gesetzgebung da kommen
und wenn wir die im herbst abgeschlossen
haben würden wäre das sicher sehr sehr
gut vor allem auch wenn wir bedenken
dass wir einerseits das gesetz regeln
wollen und andererseits auch wenn es
nach meiner gruppe geht nach unserer
gruppe die sich da zusammengefunden hat
die suizidprävention verbessern wollen
und das wäre natürlich jeder tag eher
besser frau kaputt konter vielen dank
für ihre zeit heute und wir bleiben
weiter im gespräch wir werden das thema
weiter beobachten auch wenn es ja eins
ist das jetzt um es mal so direkt zu
sagen keine große freude macht aber es
ist eben sehr wichtig also vielen dank
dass sie uns heute zur verfügung standen
um über den neuen gesetzentwurf zu
sprechen ich danke sehr frau post für
das interesse
so nach dieser schweren kost kommen wir
jetzt zu
renate künast und beleidigung im netz
also auch nicht unbedingt etwas das gute
laune macht aber ein urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts das
ja zumindest
hetzern im netz die stirn bietet oder ja
das hätte es heute auch in das gerechte
urteile rein schaffen können aber es kam
eben gerade erst rein kurz vor unserer
aufzeichnungen das heißt ich habe bisher
die pressemitteilung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts nur kurz
überflogen versuche euch aber zumindest
das wichtigste mitzugeben renate künast
hat vom bundesverfassungsgericht nämlich
recht bekommen das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat urteile aus
berlin aufgehoben gleich mehrere die
auch für relativ viel wirbel gesorgt
haben in den letzten jahren weil die
berliner gerichte renate künast die
herausgabe von nutzer in den daten von
facebook-nutzern weitgehend verweigert
haben also es ging darum dass renate
künast bei facebook übelst beschimpft
ich sag's einfach mal juristisch neutral
wurde es ging um kommentare zu einem
post der renate künast unzutreffend und
völlig aus dem zusammenhang gerissen
vorwarf pädophilie zu akzeptieren und da
wurde dann eben also dieser post war
schon an sich ja sehr schwierig sehr
problematisch und versprach auch nicht
den tatsachen und unten drunter ging es
dann richtig los man kennt das ja bei
facebook man die leute danach richtig
los pöbeln also von pädophilen trawler
übermensch was bist du krank im kopf
gehirn amputiert sie wollte auch mal die
hellste kerze sein pädo dreck und so
fanden sich da wirklich hinreißen der
dinge untendrunter in den kommentaren
und renate künast ist ja nun auch
tatsächlich eine eine kämpferin ich sag
mal für den guten ton und gegen die
hetze in den sozialen netzwerken und
zieht dadurch die instanzen hat aber vor
dem lg berlin und vor dem kg berlin
sogar überwiegend verloren weil das
landgericht und das kg diese äußerungen
und auch zahlreiche weitere nicht als
beleidigung bewertet hatten denn
hintergrund ist man kriegt die
bestandsdaten von solchen nutzern vom
sozialen netzwerk in diesem fall
facebook halt nur dann wenn man den
anspruch darauf hat und den hat man
wiederum nur wenn man zivilrechtliche
ansprüche geltend machen möchte weil man
in absolut geschützten rechten verletzt
worden ist durch rechtswidrige inhalte
so also weil die frage haben wir hier
rechtswidrige inhalte mit den renate
künast in ihren persönlichkeitsrechten
verletzt wurde und da haben das lg und
das caritas kg etwas weniger dann
tatsächlich gesagt diese dinge würden
nicht den tatbestand der beleidigung
erfüllen also 185 bis 187
strafgesetzbuch da haben sich schon sehr
viele menschen damals gewundert also das
lg hatte noch viel mehr durchgehen
lassen als dann das kg das kg das waren
noch viel mehr fälle als das was ich
jetzt zitiert haben das waren halt
dutzende von kommentar das kg hatte
schon so ein bisschen eingeschränkt und
hatte gesagt doch doch da sind doch noch
mehr dinge strafbar und deswegen liebe
frau künast kriegen haben sie auch einen
anspruch darauf noch mehr nutzerdaten zu
kriegen aber jetzt ist das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat wirklich
eingeschritten und hat gesagt das sind
auch in abwägung mit der
meinungsfreiheit dieser facebook nutzer
innen ganz klar beleidigungen und zwar
auch wenn es bei den äußerungen um das
wirken von renate künast als politikerin
geht das ist tatsächlich ein sehr
spannender aspekt weil das lg und das kg
jeweils darauf abgestellt hätten dass
renate künast im prinzip als person des
öffentlichen lebens viel mehr einstecken
können muss und da sagt das
bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt sehr klar
macht kritik und so weiter ist zwar
erlaubt aber nicht auch jede
beschimpfung die total ins persönliche
geht und gegenüber öffentlicher
verächtlichmachung und gegenüber hitze
setzt die verfassung grenzen und zwar
auch für personen des öffentlichen
lebens und für amtsträgerin und
amtsträger und da ist auch noch ein
echtes grundsatzurteil oder zu dieser
frage wie ich habe das selbst natürlich
schmecken aber ja also für mich liest es
sich ganz klar so dass sie durchaus
sagen irgendwie also auch wenn man
vielleicht mehr einstecken muss wenn es
sozusagen das betrifft wofür ich
öffentlich stehe dann heißt das nicht
dass ich als person und als mensch total
angegangen werden darf und das
bundesverfassungsgericht sagt sogar auch
in seiner pressemitteilung schon mit
blick auf soziale netzwerke und den ton
der da herrscht sei der schutz der
persönlichkeitsrechte der betroffenen
besonders wichtig nicht nur für sie
selbst sondern auch im öffentlichen
interesse denn und das sagt das
bundesverfassungsgericht genauso eine
bereitschaft zur mitwirkung in staat und
gesellschaft kann nur wartet werden wenn
für diejenigen die sich engagieren und
öffentlich einbringen ein hinreichender
schutz ihrer persönlichkeitsrechte
gewährleistet ist das würde ihm sehr
schaden den us-star das interessante und
das ist ja das was auch
kommunalpolitiker zum beispiel immer
wieder
ja den punkt den sie machen nämlich dass
man wenn man so viel einstecken muss und
so wenig geschützt wird und das ist ja
nicht nur einstecken das ist ja wirklich
öffentlich aufs mieseste
beschimpft werden die haben teilweise
angst es gibt ja auch gewalttätige
übergriffe auf politiker und da sind die
auf kommunaler ebene viel weniger
geschützt sie sagen wer will das denn
dann eigentlich noch machen häufig
ehrenamtlich ohne geld nach der arbeit
am wochenende und zu diesem preis
insofern da gibt es ja schon eine eine
sorge
dass das die leute sich das überlegen
und sagen tut mir leid danke gerade
frauen die noch viel häufiger
beleidigungen ausgesetzt sind als männer
und eben auch geschlechtsspezifisch
genau sexualisierte beleidigung und all
das insofern ja interessant dass jetzt
dass es dann vielleicht der letzte
akt in dieser causa kühnert müssen jetzt
die muss facebook da jetzt eigentlich
auch die namen der das war ja auch
nämlich gegenstand der anderen
entscheidungen die namen rausgeben der
täter es geht darum das ist sozusagen
also das landgericht und das kg wurden
ja angerufen weil renate künast die
namen der derbe schimpfenden haben
möchte so zu sagen und die kriegst du
eben nur wenn du sagen kannst ich bin
hier beleidigt worden und damit massiv
in meinen persönlichkeitsrechten
verletzt und ich will gegen die
zivilrechtlich vorgehen da musst du zu
gericht laufen und sagen liebes gericht
sorg mal dafür ort einmal an dass
facebook die namen gibt so diese beiden
entscheidungen aus berlin sind jetzt
aufgehoben worden das heißt das wird
dann jetzt neu gerichtlich angeordnet
werden müssen und dann muss facebook die
namen und die beleidigung ist die
vorfrage sozusagen die juristisch
geklärt werden muss war erst wenn es
sich um eine straße eine beleidigung und
eine rechtswidrige handlung damit ich
überhaupt einen anspruch darauf habe
dass facebook mit irgendwelchen
nutzerdaten herausgeben weil sonst
könnte ja jeder kommen sozusagen was
eine perfekte überleitung ist zu unserem
nächsten facebook urteil denn wer weiß
ob diese beschimpfen den menschen
darunter ihren klarnamen aufgetreten
sind kann ihnen schön das urteil für uns
dabei von den letzten woche so ist es
hier bist du eigentlich bei facebook
unter seinem klarnamen aktiv
also ich bin bei facebook und nicht und
haben einen klaren aktive
jugend woche für dich jetzt total
relevant wie auch für alle anderen die
sich vor april 2018 oder bis
einschließlich april 2018 bei facebook
angemeldet haben für mich ist es nicht
und wannweil ich noch nicht bei facebook
bin sollte ich mir das nochmal überlegen
trifft es mir mich tatsächlich nicht
also worum geht es es geht darum dass
viele menschen nicht nur nokia unter
pseudonym bei facebook auftreten auch
deswegen weil sie nicht unbedingt so
beschimpft werden wollen oder weil sie
nicht oder weiß ich jedenfalls nicht
unter ihrem echten namen beschimpft
werden wollen weil sie auch auf anderen
wegen dann keine post und so weiter
bekommen sollen also sind irgendwie
verständliche gründe und trotzdem haben
wir natürlich die kehrseite dessen was
wir jetzt sehen im fall renate künast
man weiß schlicht nicht wer diese
personen sind also wie immer haben wir
solche
solche geschichten 22 seiten genau die
manche menschen möchten natürlich ihren
echten namen auch nicht preisgeben nicht
weil sie nicht beschimpft werden wollen
sondern sondern weil die schimpfen ohren
das ist natürlich nur sofern was hat
facebook gemacht facebook hatte immer
schon allgemeine geschäftsbedingungen in
denen es hieß jeder nutzer muss sein
muss sich unter richtigen namen anmelden
und diesen auch auf facebook
verwenden das haben aber viele nicht
getan und
haben daraufhin sich eben unter
pseudonym angemeldet und was hat
facebook gemacht facebook hat einfach
die konten gesperrt dagegen haben in
diesem fall ein mann und eine frau
geklagt und haben gesagt diese
allgemeinen geschäftsbedingungen sind
benachteiligend und damit unwirksam
der un- haben verwiesen auf das
telemediengesetz denn dort wäre es ganz
genau wissen wir den paragraph 16 stand
jedenfalls bis november 20 21 drin dass
anbieter
die nutzung ihrer dienste anonym und
oder unter pseudonym zu ermöglichen
haben also das gesetz sah vor das war ja
auch noch vielleicht hat sich die ich
sag mal denke umgangssprachlich auch ein
bisschen verändert dass man damals sagte
na ja das netz ist halt dieser raum der
freiheit in der man natürlich auch unter
anonym aktiv sein darf das sehen ja
viele heute aufgrund der erfahrung sehr
viel kritischer jedenfalls damals war es
aber so und dann war das argument ja
doch recht stark zu sagen als er gibt es
allgemeine geschäftsbedingungen die
dieser rechtsnormen telemediengesetz
diametral entgegenstehen und so sieht es
jetzt eben auch der bgh unwirksam sind
so dass wer sich vor april 218
angemeldet hat weiter unter seinem
pseudonym aktiv sein darf und facebook
eben diese konnten nicht sperren darf
warum ist abriss dinge zwei sachen genau
warum april 2018 muss ich einmal ganz
kurz klugscheißern es war nicht der
paragraph 16 und § 13 absatz 6
entschuldigung 13
du hast völlig recht
darstellt ich habe mir 16 hier auch
geschrieben genau 13 6 ist außer kraft
getreten ende november 20 21 wieso ist
denn jetzt das maßgebliche datum über
das der bgh entschieden hat jetzt der 25
mai 2018 gerne auch weil was uns am 25
02 18 in kraft getreten die dsgv die
datenschutz grund verordnung eine
europäische verordnung die in allen
mitgliedstaaten unmittelbar und direkt
gilt über die wir hier auch schon häufig
gesprochen haben die viel papierkram mit
sich bringt aber natürlich auch ein
bisschen was gutes oder manche sagen
auch viel gutes für den datenschutz auch
darüber kann man noch mal streiten aber
jedenfalls ist nach dieser in dieser
dsgv steht zum thema anonym oder unter
pseudonym im netz aktiv seien schlicht
gar nichts so das ist jetzt eine frage
ist es gibt eben leute die sagen die
dsgv die eben keine regelung zu diesem
thema enthält top jetzt das
telemediengesetz paar auf 13 6 und so
dass dieser diese normen jetzt quasi
keine gültigkeit mehr hätte oder
jedenfalls in diesem fall eher verdrängt
würde und andere sagen nein also diese
frage ist weiterhin ungeklärt deswegen
hat facebook auch sofort reagiert mit
einer stellungnahme und gesagt also
diese dieser bgh fall betrifft nur
altfälle so also das ist natürlich
juristisch gesehen auch irgendwie
richtig trotzdem ist es natürlich so
dass ja alle menschen die sich
angemeldet haben bei facebook vor dem 25
mai 2018 von diesem urteil jetzt
insofern betroffen sind als sie ihren
mix oder ihren pseudonym behalten dürfen
insofern ist das jetzt natürlich schon
mehr als irgendwie so ein langweiliges
urteil zu einer alten rechtslage sondern
schon in gewisser hinsicht ein
grundsatzurteil nur hilft uns das nicht
so richtig für die zeit also für die
menschen die sich danach angemeldet
haben oder die sich jetzt sogar noch
anmelden dass sich noch anmelden und ich
würde sagen seit november 20 21 als
dieser bank auf 13 telemediengesetz eben
abgeschafft wurde ist die rechtslage
relativ klar da gilt die dsgv und die
enthält eben keine bestimmung zur
anonymität und deswegen gilt dann halt
würde dieser würde dieser allgemeinen
geschäftsbedingungen von facebook die
eben zur nutzung von klarnamen
verpflichtet jetzt nichts im wege stehen
ungeklärt ist eben noch diese
zwischenzeit ich habe mich gefragt ihr
ist es denn warum kommt es denn
eigentlich auf den zeitpunkt der
anmeldung an man könnte das doch
irgendwie auch als dauer verhältnis
sehen und sagen na ja man hat sich halt
einmal angemeldet da war es anders aber
mit dem inkrafttreten der dsgv und
spätestens mit dem außer kraft treten
des telemediengesetzes muss man dann
sind eben auch sein verhalten anpassen
naja aber es geht er am ende um agb das
ganze findet ja innerhalb der agb
prüfung statt und die agb prüfung kann
sich ja nur danach richten wann der
vertrag abgeschlossen wurde also in
quasi welche agb in den vertrag
einbezogen wurden deswegen muss es halt
der zeitpunkt der anmeldung sein denn da
hast du doch bestimmt also hättest du
bist ja nicht bei facebook hättest du ja
sicherlich auch die 15 seiten lang agb
gelesen und angeklickt und gesagt ich
bin damit einverstanden ja das mache ich
alles mit und da sieht man nicht jedes
mal wenn man sich neu
einloggt sozusagen konkludent wieder
sondern das macht man beim vertrag ist
ein sehr treffendes schlagendes argument
so das ist aber tatsächlich auch wenn es
jetzt halt es betrifft altfälle wie du
gesagt hast einen sehr sehr großen teil
der facebook nutzer
betrifft denn so sehe ich das jedenfalls
oder höre dass ich ja selber wie gesagt
nicht dabei das facebook jedenfalls bei
jüngeren leuten schon längst total out
ist und sich da ja jeder manager bei
facebook ist der ist da halt schon immer
und ich glaube nicht dass das jetzt noch
so eine großartige relevanz haben wird
wer sich da jetzt für die menschen die
sich nur über facebook anmelden einfach
weil er sehr sehr wenige menschen sein
dürften ich bin aber nicht so richtig
bei dir das ist jetzt alles schon so für
die zukunft ganz klar ist dass facebook
dann die klarnamen pflicht wirklich
einführen darf weil der bgh hat schon
noch so eine abwägung der reingeschoben
in seinem urteil die eigentlich gar
nicht erforderlich gewesen wäre weil er
halt einfach hätte sagen können 13
absatz setzt 6 tmg hat damals gegolten
damit gab es ein recht auf anonymität
jetzt hat der wege ja schon gesagt naja
eigentlich würde es ja schon ausreichen
dass zwar facebook seine kundinnen und
kunden namentlich kennt also dass man
seinen echten namen bei der anmeldung
angeben muss aber das heißt ja nicht
zwingen das dann man diesen echten namen
auch als nutzernamen nutzen müsste so
dass auch andere userinnen und user wir
sind echte namen tatsächlich kennen
müssten also ich finde diese abwägung
die würde die könnte durchaus auch noch
für die zukunft tragen so dass ich jetzt
noch gar nicht so richtig weiß ob er der
dsgv einfluss wirklich so viel ändern
wird aber gut dass hier kann man sich
auch einfach herr marcel das kann man
sicherlich auch diskutieren wobei es
dann ja schlicht keine regelung gibt die
sozusagen dieser agb im entgegensteht
und wenn wir jetzt an renate künast
denken wissen wir auch wie schwierig der
weg ist als jemand der zum beispiel von
beleidigung betroffen ist dann an den
echten namen zu kommen denn der ist
unter welchem namen jemand registriert
ist das sehe ich ja nicht als andere das
sind eben genau die von dir recht
zitierten zwei seiten das sind
vermutlich genau diese zwei seiten denn
es gibt natürlich auch sehr gute gründe
die dafür sprechen dass man im netz
anonym unterwegs sein darf es gibt gute
gründe dafür und dagegen und von daher
denke ich mal das wird uns auch noch
länger beschäftigen diese frage sie ist
auf jeden fall glaube ich jetzt noch nie
final geklärt auch nicht für die
sozialen netzwerke okay aber jedenfalls
ich merke mir unter dem strich ich muss
mich jetzt auch bei facebook nicht mehr
anmelden wenn ich bisher ohne trotz
gekommen bin das kann so sagen ich
glaube du solltest dann lieber zu
instagram gehen oder so ist auch wie
netter und lustiger das ist da viel
schöner friedlicher die
diskussionskultur ist viel entspannter
und so war kann das eigentlich unter
vielen aspekten nur empfehlen schon los
okay dann muss ich viele fotos kosten ja
weiß ich nicht ich werde mir überlegen
ich bin wirklich mit den übrigen
chameleon schon ganz gut bedient dient
so ist es
so und damit kommen wir jetzt schon zum
gerechten urteil wie schon angedeutet
heute sehr passend zum 22 22 und als wir
uns im vorfeld kurz besprochen haben
hast du schon gesagt oh gott ja was ein
glück dass herr mein bruder auch
passiert so ist es jedenfalls so so
ähnlich als mein bruder ist jedenfalls
opfer geworden von corinna insofern dass
er seine hochzeit gleich zwei mal
verschieben musste
erstmal sie bis
2020 geplant und dann für mai 2021 fand
dann aber wunderbar statt im august 2021
draußen bei herrlichem sommerwetter ein
fotograf unter der haube und er hatte
auch einen fotografen engagiert mit dem
was irgendwie geeinigt hat denn ihm ist
es so gegangen wie es auch und so ein
paar in diesem fall über das
amtsgericht münchen entschieden hat
gegen sie haben einen
hochzeitsfotografen für ihre hochzeit
mit standesamtlich und kirchlich trauen
und anschließender feier gebucht haben
ausgemacht ein honorar von 3000 euro
haben die hälfte als vorschuss bezahlt
und dann durfte die feier überhaupt
nicht stattfinden
die beiden haben zwei standesamtlich
geheiratet aber die ganze feier musste
abgesagt werden weil das damals aufgrund
der kontakt beschränkung überhaupt nicht
möglich gewesen wäre und dann haben sie
gesagt von den 1500 euro die sie bereits
gezahlt hatten wollten sie zumindest
1000 euro zurückhaben und haben gesagt
wir haben ein rücktrittsrecht die
fertigung dieser fotos war eben objektiv
zu dem zeitpunkt als sie gefeiert haben
nämlich mit 20 21 also tatsächlich auch
das datum haben die mein bruder das
zweite mal heute war objektiv ist aber
übrigens nicht mein bruder nur mit hier
keine geschichte in sich schreibt man
hat uns nur zufälligerweise dasselbe
datum
ist eben objektiv nicht möglich gewesen
und das unternehmen warnte ein nein
entschuldigung wir haben allgemeine
geschäftsbedingung dass da steht die
anzahlung von 50 prozent wird
eingehalten auch wenn die hochzeit eben
aufgrund von höherer gewalt nicht
durchgeführt werden kann sozusagen pech
gehabt man muss natürlich sagen dass für
die solo selbstständigen und das ist
jetzt in dem teil vielleicht der
fotograf vielleicht nicht das weiß jetzt
nicht so genau aber für diese leute war
es natürlich sehr hart die hatten laut
verpflichtungen sind sie eingegangen und
haben dann leben dann mit nichts zurück
und hatten wir einfach schlicht keine
aufträge mehr weil es keine hochzeit
wird keine feiern und so weiter gab also
insofern irgendwo wirtschaftlich
verständlich aber natürlich für dieses
hochzeitspaar auch nicht schön und jetzt
entschied das amtsgericht münchen und
sagte nein es ist der fotograf muss
tatsächlich das geld
zurückbezahlen denn diesem ehepaar steht
ein rücktrittsrecht zu und warum das ist
jetzt schuld recht die würde ich sagen
hier liegt ein insofern könnte auch
dieser fall tatsächlich klausur relevant
seien hier liegt ein absolutes fix
geschäft vor so das amtsgericht münchen
denn sie sagten ja es wäre es war eben
nur zu diesem einen zeitpunkt möglich
als die feier geplant war wäre es
möglich gewesen wäre alles normal
gelaufen diese fotos zu machen man wird
nicht hinterher noch mal sozusagen die
hochzeit nachstellen können und den
fahrer und die eltern freunde und sonst
was das hochzeitskleid nochmal anziehen
und sich dann irgendwie nach der
pandemie versammeln und diese fotos
nachholen sondern hochzeitsfotos sind ja
nicht irgendwelche fotos sondern das
sind die fotos die tatsächlich am tag
der hochzeit entstehen und da das dann
unmöglich geworden ist eben durch die
regelungen zu den kontakt beschränkungen
war es tatsächlich ein absolutes fix
geschäft das nicht nachzuholen war und
somit hat das ehepaar jedenfalls diese
1000 euro
zurückbekommen und das finden wir
eigentlich zutiefst gerecht ist es tut
uns leid für den fotografen wie gesagt
habe ich jetzt mit einbezogen die sind
auch arm dran aber für ein hochzeitspaar
das sowieso schon alle freunde wieder
ausladen musste und die ganze feier
nicht so stattfinden konnte und die
haben sich ja wie es so ist
wahrscheinlich ewig darauf vorbereitet
geplant gemacht das ist schon bitter
genug und wenn man dann noch auf den
kosten sitzen bleibt finden wir das
zutiefst gerecht dass das in dem fall
nicht so ist vor allem an diesem tag
heute am zweiten
2022 denkt daran es kommt auch noch der
22 also falls noch jemand in der stadt
leben nicht für die nächsten 18 monate
ausgebucht standesämter hat könnt ihr
euch noch überlegen ob ihr euren frauen
und männern anträge machen möchte der 22
fast noch schöner und mit diesem
wunderschönen urteil zum schluss würde
ich sagen was es für heute oder lehne ja
hier schön dass wir nach so eine
fröhliche kurve gekriegt haben das freut
mich sehr hat spaß gemacht kommen gut
durch die woche und in der kommenden
woche ist dann wieder corinna aus berlin
ja ich will eins und gewogen
[Musik]